social democracy versus Democratic
socialism very similar words in a
different order okay
my the way I operate is democratic
socialism is actually a form of
Socialism where one would seek to
socialize ownership of the means of
production as an example social
democracy is a very uh highly regulated
form of capitalism the likes of which we
would see in northern Europe Denmark Etc
these are very different things I
associate progressivism in 2023 with
social democracy and would consider
Democratic socialism a form of actual
socialism that is different it is we're
no longer talking about a capitalist
organization of society